thousands of people have fled their
homes near the town of sake in eastern
Democratic Republic of Congo a coalition
of armed groups that's been allied with
government forces split the factions
turned on each
other we're leaving because for 3 days
now our village and the surrounding area
has been under gunfire and I don't know
what is happening we are going in order
to save our lives because we are afraid
congales government forces have been
fighting M23 a Rwandan backed armed
group it's the latest round of a
conflict that started in the 1990s
Rwanda denies it's involved Congo's
governments relied on support from other
armed groups but things haven't always
gone to
plan rights groups say this video shows
the bodies of about 60 fighters from an
armed group once allied with the
government they say government troops
killed them and some of their families
on Tuesday near the city of Benny after
a Fallout the Army denies
it its soldiers have struggled to
contain M23 advances in the last two
years the congales government's been
seeking foreign support an East African
Regional Force came and went without
ending the conflict a force from
Southern African countries deployed last
month but most of its troops have not
yet
arrived it is very clear that the
mission of the force from the southern
African development Community is
offensive contrary to the other missions
we had here this is what we and our
population are expecting from this
Mission more than half a million people
have fled their homes since M23
restarted an old conflict 2 years
ago most people here a skeptical that
yet more foreign forces can help Malcolm
Webb Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer